a coisa e ela vai fazer com que isso não
[Música]
são mesmo tempo não é
a pessoa semana nós terminamos a mesma
[Música]
vamos lá vou dizer vou lá pagar alguns a
visão e o salário o
E aí
o caminhão cavalo-trator não é baixa
E o frio não tomaram o controle de
volante
o carnaval fazemos um alguma vez todos
nós
a contar para sua mãe
e nós vamos acrescentando horas como se
não tem nada para o nome de Jesus não é
[Música]
Oi tudo bem
Olá eu sou eu
[Música]
E aí
o salário não fala um lugar aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou o povo por favor
e eu não sabia disso não
[Música]
e olha não é
E aí
o Marcelo para descobrir inventam de
França a letra a
o senador não é
[Música]
bom então alguma como psicólogo Olha aí
e não é
[Música]
O amor venceu de novo não tem bolo não é
E aí galera logo vê-se envolvido no
trabalho eu não tenho fogo pois é
[Música]
E aí
e ainda não é
[Música]
E aí
se não der hoje a celular não é
o curso uma
E aí
o mais novo eu não é
o nosso bolo televisão né
um novo cenário para você responder não
é
[Música]
é muito carinho não é
E aí